well micro-insurance is very simple it's
an insurance policy sold at a low
premium to a poor person with a lower
pay out but that payoff matters hugely
to them so a woman might need to go to
the hospital but she has no safety net
no resources to fall back on
so she's forced to either bankrupt the
family or spend all their savings or not
go to the hospital and the consequences
for her and for her family can be
profound
now what insurance allows her to do is
pay a small premium each month it might
be a dollar it might be four dollars it
might be seven dollars but fundamentally
that allows that poor woman if an
unexpected event happens to be able to
go to the hospital to be able to get
medication to recover and not bankrupt
the whole family or lose all their
assets the same is true of life
insurance people save and save for years
scrimping people who earn very few
dollars every day and slowly cumulate
assets and then one day as happens to
all of us for years in or two years in
some terrible event happens the
breadwinner dies and you and they can
immediately have all their debts that
they have to repay they can have the
funeral costs which can often be
significant in parts of Africa and are
necessary for continued participation in
the community and they lose all the
assets everything they've been working
for and a whole family business that
supports say the three kids and all
their kids can go down the drain and
these are real stories I'm not making
these up and what insurance allows
people to do is to recover from that
shock so the breadwinner dies within two
days there's a payout people can pay for
the funeral people can pay off their
loans people can have some money to
continue the business and get it to a
point where they can run it six months
later so this insurance may seem like a
small thing because it only costs a few
dollars but it provides people with the
ability to recover from shock and
actually globally studies have shown
particularly the work of Nobel laureate
Amartya Sen has shown that the poram
poor often because they have these
adverse shocks they do actually
accumulate assets over time and then
they fall back under the poverty line so
the the importance of this cannot be
underestimated I think it is the one of
the most central if not the most central
development interventions in the world
and the exciting thing is it's
profitable now just to take a step back
that why is it profitable well if you
think in pure actuarial hard-nosed
business terms insurance is about risk
and it's about predicting what's going
to happen an insurance company takes
money tries to predict what's going to
happen and promises to make a certain
payout at a later at a later date and it
takes some money for doing that and for
sharing the risk pool for organizing a
risk pool now what makes something
predictable well it's large numbers you
would rather have a million people
you're insuring at a lower cost then a
thousand people you're insuring at for a
higher premium that they're going to pay
so the incredibly exciting thing about
micro insurance is you can sell a huge
numbers of policies at low margins to
huge numbers of people and your risk
pool becomes quite predictable and that
makes it much easier to manage so even
though you're taking a smaller cut on
each policy you're actually doing
fundamentally in some ways a better
business now the important thing is
you've really got to get your costs low
because if you're selling a policy for
seven dollars adding on fifty cents here
or there is going to create real
problems so one of the really exciting
things is the technology and the systems
that allow you to do this so micro
insurance is now being sold through cell
phones people are working through groups
like churches where people where you
know in South Africa three million
people come to the zdc church every
Sunday and they buy a lot of them by
micro insurance and it's a very
successful scheme pot owned by the law
just ensure in Africa microfinance
institutions when people walk in for a
loan you add 2% and suddenly those
people have coverage so that the loan is
repaid so that they are covered in the
event of the death of a breadwinner and
so that they have a better a better
outlook now the the last exciting thing
here is it's not just about protection
in terms of social impact its hugely
important because it's enabling so think
of a farmer I myself have had bad
experiences failed development
experiences where I went to India and
tried to get farmers to adopt certain
drip irrigation technology and others
have done this with seeds trying to give
its seeds that really help increase
productivity and farmers said no and we
couldn't work it out we thought look
this has a 95% chance of success they're
going to triple their income their
family is going to climb out of poverty
why are these farmers not doing it and
the answer is there's a 5% chance of
failure and 5% chance of failure of any
new business for these people means that
their children starve so how many of us
are going to undertake a new business
when there's a one in 20 chance that our
children starve
now what micro-insurance can do for
things like crop insurance for instance
is help people to take worthwhile risks
so people know that their assets of
their family are protected that their
loans are repaid if they die that they
aren't going to leave their family
destitute they know that if the crop
fails because of something entirely
outside of their control that they'll be
able to get a payout so they're able to
engage in new forms of economic activity
they're able to take risks that allow
them to dramatically in some cases
increase their income so it's not only
protective micro-insurance it's enabling
and that is what I think makes it one of
the world's most important development
interventions